were you a business major at USC no I
was a theater major so you wanted to be
an actor yeah and then you decide to
turn to producing yeah what you doing
now well just left it's all been a a
path designed to get me into directing i
started out at a very young age I lived
in Washington DC when I was a child and
I got a role in a professional
production of Christmas Carol and
actually the guy who played a bob
cratchit it was David strathern so you
know it's a really good show that they
do every year and at Ford's Theatre
where Lincoln got shot and at that point
I you know was like 12 and collecting
checks and thought this was a pretty
good idea to stick with it so I ended up
acting my entire childhood and applied
to the conservatory acting program at
USC and got in and then came out to Los
Angeles because I figured this was
ground zero for film and television and
worked through a bunch of you know you
have to act in a production every
semester at USC as part of the
curriculum and after my sophomore year I
started to want a little bit more than
just being in front of the camera and
getting behind the camera or getting
behind the scenes was the next step so I
went into the Dean and asked if I could
direct to play every semester instead of
acting in one and they were like yeah
they had plenty of actors so they let me
direct a show and so my last two years I
directed my first four shows and then
ran a theater company out of school and
started going along I mean it's a it's a
long story but what was that that made
you turn where did you go because so
many people come here they want to be in
front of camera even if they say they're
to want to be a director it's a ruse to
get somehow in front of the camera even
you know someone who's saying
orthodontist have headshots I here so
everybody well it seems to want to be in
from the camera what what was that shift
what was it originally like my love for
this sort of life the life in
entertainment started with my stepfather
who was a theater critic and I lived it
when i was living in London as a child
he used to take me because they don't
get two tickets and he I used to I was
his plus one and a lot of plays as a
young child and I said you know they
fell in love with that idea of a being
on stage of being in theater so when I
got back to Washington DC I had the
opportunity to try out for those
productions I've worked as you know
worked in Christmas Carol as Tiny Tim
and and then ended up at USC so it does
go all the way back to that but yes the
professor at USC that I had he had seen
that I was going out on auditions I had
a commercial agent I book the commercial
here and you know did some things but I
started to get a little frustrated with
not being the exact person that you that
you have to be you know on the other
side of the desk the people you know the
directors the producers have something
in mind and if you're not that exact
person they just go on to the next one
they try to find it and I I wasn't
willing to let my entire career be
defined by whether or not I happen to be
the right person when I walked in the
door I wanted much more control you know
in my life and so when the professor
offered me an associate director ship on
this production I took it I was like
it's you know I want to explore what
this would be all about and I really you
know found that it it it opened up a lot
more a lot more avenues for me it didn't
it wasn't just about being the one
character playing the one the one role
so much of the interpretation of the
literature and you know the screenplay
or the script you know dealing with the
lighting and the music and working with
all the actors was it was just such so
much of a more of a world and the other
thing is is you know you get judged on
your style of what you produce and
anyone you know you can be any size
shape color and you know if you have an
idea you have a story that you want to
tell it's the story that matters and
ultimately you know I like I mean that's
the thing for me above all when I'm
working on a what I'm producing or
directing I focus all my energy on the
story and developing that story and you
know bringing the vision not only in my
head but in everyone
else that I'm collaborating with you
know so that's what that's what was when
that world up it up to me acting just it
wasn't it it was it was great but it
wasn't as fulfilling as as working as a
director producer it is
you